I'm joined today by Arthur Bryant
chairman of public justice you can find
out more at public justice dotnet a
national public interest law firm that
pursues high-impact lawsuits to combat
social and economic injustice protect
the earth sustainability and challenge
predatory corporate conduct and
government abuses and today Arthur were
talking about Remington the firearms
manufacturer this is a story that I
spoke to a number of people that you
know I told them we would be speaking to
you about this and many people that sort
of follow the firearms industry had no
idea what I was talking about when I
talked about the remington gun scandal
so let's start at the beginning how far
back does this go and what are we
talking about well the problem actually
goes back to the 1940s amazing so but
what we're talking about is the single
most popular rifle in America the
Remington 700 and a dozen other
Remington models all have a horrific
dangerous defect they can on occasion
because of the defective design of the
trigger fire when no one pulls the
trigger I am not kidding about this it
is horrific we serious anyone who owns
one of these over seven and a half
million rifles is it risk of the gun
firing when no one pulls the trigger
people have been gun owners themselves
have been shot family members have been
shot loved ones have been shot innocent
third parties have been shot by these
rifles they are still being shot all of
the time the problem is so serious that
Remington although still falsely denying
that there's a problem has now agreed to
retrofit virtually all of these rifles
are almost all of these rifles with a
free trigger replacement if people make
a claim but
every few people know about this very
few people are making a claim yet and so
everyone needs to know so they stopped
using these rifles and they filed claims
to get the free trigger retrofit so
Arthur that's sort of like an automotive
recall except when you've got an
automotive recall everybody who has or
is believed to have a particular
affected vehicle gets a letter
there's not even a system in place which
would conceivably allow that to take
place here is there well in theory
everyone with one of these right there
well let me back up there is no system
in place to get everybody a letter
you're absolutely right and it's
different in a couple of other ways from
automotive recalls first the federal
government regulates automobiles and so
the federal government can order a
recall with guns however the federal
government does no regulation of guns
the National Rifle Association
acclaiming the Second Amendment protects
guns from regulation as effective we've
stopped almost all federal regulation of
guns so when a gun is defective at the
Remington 700s and it's shooting when no
one pulls the trigger and killing people
the federal government still can't do
anything about it
it comes down to trial lawyers and
people who have been injured bringing
lawsuits and making the huge difference
and ultimately forcing the company to do
the right thing and Arthur when you say
the gun fires when one is not attempting
to fire it is this when the firearms are
being otherwise handled or is it when a
firearm is potentially just stored and
loaded it could fire on its own well
it's basically whenever the gun if it's
stored away safely and no one touches it
or touches the container in which it's
stored no it will not fire let me give
you first of all anybody who wants to
see what the problem is public just
has gotten unsealed every document in
every lawsuit and there have been over a
hundred brought against remington on
behalf of people who were shot injured
killed maimed by these rifles we've
gotten all unsealed you need to go to
WWE and documents calm we've posted the
key documents on the website so everyone
can see just what the danger is and why
they need to protect themselves we have
power points up there we have the key
documents themselves up there over a
hundred eight thousand documents up
there but we highlighted the key ones we
need to people need to protect
themselves they need to stop using these
rifles until they get the retrofit
either through a proposed class action
settlement in a case called Pollard
versus Remington or on their own because
too many people have been injured and
killed by these rifles I'd love for you
to talk a little bit about what
Remington has and has not sort of
admitted to at this point and and how to
the question in this way I read about
the case of rich and Barbara Barbour who
lost their nine-year-old son to this
this defect in October of the year 2000
and I also read that Remington quickly
settled the case when they were sued by
the barbers at the same time I'm also
reading that while Remington is willing
to fix the problem there's a number of
reports and I hope you can explain this
Remington has denied wrongdoing so can
you explain sort of what this all means
together I'll do my best
yeah we first learned about first
anybody who doesn't know what public
justice is it is a national public
interest law firm that takes on cases
that need to be brought basically
whether or not they'll make any money
just because of the public interest and
just because of the danger to the public
involved so if you want to learn more
about us go to WWE justice net we work
on the story it really starts with
which barber and barber barber like to
say which barber is an NRA member from
Montana an avid marksman a shooter a gun
rights advocate he and his wife and his
two kids would regularly go out hunting
for the weekend that was their weekend
activity family activity many years ago
over a decade ago they come back from a
hunting trip
Richard barbers wife Barbara is
unloading the rifles at that time she's
unloading their Remington 700 you have
to take off the safety to unload the
rifle she takes off the safety her
finger is nowhere near the trigger and
the gun fires on its own the bullet goes
through their trailer ricochets off the
door and hits their nine and shoots and
kills their nine-year-old son Gus barb
just imagine now they are utterly
devastated they do find a lawyer
actually a member that a public justices
Board of managers now deceased and
Richard Miller who had several lawsuits
already against Remington for an
incident as horrific as this Richard
Miller and Richard barber file a lawsuit
Remington quickly settles it offers
money and rich barber bless him says
that's not good enough
I know guns I am not willing to settle
this case unless Remington agrees to
work with me to come up with a safe
design for this trigger because this
can't happen to anybody else and
Remington agrees and rich barber and
Remington then work together to develop
a new trigger design which is called the
x mark Pro the original trigger design
was called the Walker fire control now
so to make clear what's wrong with it
the Walker fire control is the only
trigger in a history that has two
different pieces to it one is called a
trigger connector the other is the
trigger body and the problem is
the trigger connector does not always
reset like it's supposed to and on
occasion their metal shavings come off
the trigger or even some other kind of
impediment gets in there it can get
between the trigger connector and the
trigger body making the whole thing
either way so unstable that if anybody
bumps the rifle if you put the safety on
the rifle if you take the safety off the
rifle several other things the rifle
will shoot on its own and so they
develop actually a new trigger design to
replace the Walker fire control it's
called the X market Pro and Richard
barber believes he has a deal with
Remington that when this new trigger
goes into production
they will recall and retrofit the seven
and a half million guns out there with
the old defective Walker fire control
because otherwise the same thing could
happen to other kids that happen to his
son
Gus and what happens is he finds out by
the time it goes into production that
they're not retrofitting and recalling
anything and so he calls me because he
knows public justice has a project about
secrecy in the courts he calls me to say
Arthur someone pointed me to a federal
lawsuit in Montana near my home and said
that something I needed to take a look
at this court trial he said I went to
the court file and the name on the court
file is sealed versus sealed I mean a
mannequin he said I can't tell if this
is a lawsuit against Remington or what
it's involved etc could public justice
unsealed it's we've put together a team
and we did the case was called it turns
out it was a case called Alexis's
Remington and what we discovered was
stunning first we discovered that five
years before this happened to Gus barber
the same thing that happened to someone
else
near where Richard barber lives in
Montana so he becomes furious because he
feels if it wasn't for secrecy in the
courts and
Remington conduct his son would be alive
second we learn in that court file it's
been going on for 30 40 50 years
lawsuits have been brought they fought
them some they've settled some but
they're all been they want some in the
trial they've lost some of the trials if
there were trial but everything has been
sealed so rich Barbour takes the
document to CNBC
which because is special called
Remington under fire it's now available
on the web but there was no web then
which exposes just how horrible this
problem is renting tenants that are
recalling the rifles of something
extraordinary
it pays over two million dollars we know
just for the lawyers fees to review it
over two million dollars to prepare its
own counter documentary saying CNBC
doesn't know what it's talking about
there's nothing wrong with these guns we
know that they're safe they're not
effective because we've tested them
repeatedly we've take independent
experts dismissed them and we can't get
them to fire without a trigger pool that
tells us there's nothing wrong with the
guns it's something wrong that the gun
owners are doing with them and so that's
the position it takes and rich barber
knows this isn't true so Rick's barber
valved he's going to do something still
to make sure other people don't lose
their children like he lost his first he
goes to the Montana State Legislature
and amazingly gets them to pass a law
limiting court secrecy called the named
after his son called the Gus barber
anti-secrecy the second he gets the gist
of you comes an expert witness in case
after case he knows that he can help
families who've lost people get
compensated by Remington and hold
Remington accountable if he does and
because he's an expert witness he gets
access to their documents the documents
are under seal he can't publicize them
but he has them and he creates a filing
cabinet after filing cabinet full of the
documents
and learn exactly what Remington knew in
winter grip knew it and he gets a class
action cloud called Pollard versus
Remington to get a recall and retro suit
for everyone who owns any of these kinds
now I don't know he's up to all this I
just know we unseal the elected trial
but he calls me years later actually a
year and a half ago any two years ago
now and he says all right there I need
your help again and I said what's going
on he said well I got this class action
file there's actually a proposed
settlement in the file to get the
retrofit on everybody on most of these
guns for anyone who makes a claim and I
said well congratulations you know no
congratulations I've quit the team I
said why he said well first because they
tried to get the court to agree to see
to order secrecy of all these documents
when I told them if there was any more
court secrecy I would not participate
second the settlement allows Remington
to keep claiming these guns are safe
when it they are as and third I am
scared to death that if the settlement
is approved
Remington is going to go public with a
PR campaign thing there is nothing wrong
with these guns they're all safe
you know we sell this as a business
proposition no one needs to file claims
and no one will know to file claims both
because they won't notify enough people
and because the documents are still
sealed so what i Richard Barbour have
done is I've called Remington and I've
told them you need to make all the
documents public and admit these guns
are defective and dangerous or I am
going to make all your documents public
because I have to and Remington he says
tell me if you do that rich we're going
to suit you who contempt of court all
over this country
and bankrupt you and ruin your life we
said Arthur you know me I don't care
I've lost my son I can't let this happen
to other people but of course I'd rather
not be sued for contempt of court all
over the country is there any way you
can help
and I said rich what happened when you
said they went to the court with the
motion for secrecy and he said well the
judge said that under the law you have
to prove good cause for there to be
speak whiskey and right now they hadn't
proven there was any good basis for
secrecy they just give it an escape
ulation and agreements super-sweet and
the judge wasn't going to order secrecy
based on just an agreement and I said to
them well rich I think I can help you
and I called the class Council and I
told them look we need to make these
documents public you need to go to
Remington's lawyers and tell them they
need to make these documents public or
you are going to go to the court and
seek to unseal every document and say
seek to clarify his order denying
secrecy to say now that Remington has
agreed to retrofit these rigors for
anyone who makes a claim there's no good
basis at all for keeping the documents
you put the gun owners need to know the
truth and you said aren't there why
would I endanger our settlement by
threatening that I said because if you
don't public justice is going to and we
are going to move to intervene on behalf
of not Richard barber but our new client
the Center for Investigative Reporting
and move to unseal these documents for
everyone in the country so it will be
the press will be all over it you will
have to support our motion the gun
owners want us to use documents
Remington can try to resist but the
judge is going to grant our motion and
unseal them all with the press watching
everywhere or Remington can just agree
and so Reddington did agree and we got a
written letter from Remington agreeing
that every single document every single
Remington 700 in any other single-shot
rifle case against Remington with these
triggers was now open to the public and
so we then went back to Richard barber
and told him that so he could show us
what the documents showed now Richard
was at rich barber was grateful that we
got missed but still outraged as he
showed us what the documents show
was not only there's been going on for
years but Remington had in fact tested
these rifles repeatedly and had in fact
paid experts to test these rifles
repeatedly and every time the rifles
pulled without I'm sorry
every time the rifle shot when no one
pulled the trigger Wow rare Remington
was lying Remington was lying when it
responded to CNBC's special Remington
knew these guns were defective the other
thing the documents showed is Remington
had repeatedly considered recalling
these rifles because of the defect and
at each time decided it was just going
to cost too much money and even though
it knew people were dying it no new
people were being named it was going to
deny there was a problem and continued
to sell these gun and continue to look
you know let people die and so we took
those documents back to see enviously
which then did a news special called
Remington under fire the reckoning and
exposed the truth and anybody who wants
to see those documents again we've
posted them on the whipped WWMT
documents calm your search for Remington
under fire the reckoning and you can see
them and then after we made them public
60 minutes to special so you can now go
look up Remington under Remington 700 60
minutes and what was uncovered
astonishingly and so just heartbreaking
a man named Roger Springer contacted
Richard barber and said mr Barber I just
found out what you had learned long ago
which is he's gone from fire without a
trigger pull and I'm so grateful and so
outraged because my son Zachary when he
was 14 years old was holding a Remington
700 he said I'm a hunter from
Mississippi I taught my boys to hunt he
was holding a fort view at 14 he was
sitting on his couch holding a Remington
700 it fired
and killed his seven is 11 year old
brother and my son Zachary swore you
didn't pull the trigger that he heard a
click and the gun fired on its own and
literally blew the brains off of his
younger brother and no one believed her
I didn't believe them the police didn't
believe it the only one who is I'm
actually was his mother so and he was
tried and convicted of killing his
brother his conviction was upheld by the
Mississippi Supreme Court and he's been
in prison for five years while for
killing his brother because while he
swore it fired when no one pulled the
trigger no one believed him because guns
aren't supposed to fire when you don't
pull the trigger
sure and Reddington never informed us it
never informed you know the Sheriff's
Department and 60 minutes exposed all of
this absolutely incredible Arthur I wish
we had more time but we've gone way way
over Remington documents calm of course
check out public justice dotnet as well
it's an incredible story which we're
going to continue following and I thank
you so much for talking to me about it
today thank you very much